à l'école dans les transports en commun
et même les stations essence c'est la
grève contre la réforme des retraites
aujourd'hui alors voici les plus grosses
grèves qui ont bloqué la France depuis
30 ans c'est la plus grosse grève qui a
connu la France en 1995 plus de 2
millions de personnes manifestent contre
une première réforme des retraites c'est
le plan Juppé du nom du premier ministre
de Jacques Chirac trois semaines de
grève les plus importantes depuis Mai 68
qui font céder le gouvernement puis en
mai 2003 encore contre la réforme des
retraites de François Fillon cette
fois-ci un mouvement de grève a lieu
dans la fonction publique un million de
personnes manifestent mais le
gouvernement réussi à faire passer la
réforme octobre 2007 sous Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est au tour des cheminots de
se mettre en grève les transports sont
paralysés pendant une dizaine de jours
mais le gouvernement ne cède pas
rebelote pourtant en 2010 contre le
relèvement de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite juin 2016 souffrance ou
Hollande cette fois c'est la loi el
khomri pour réformer le code du travail
qui met la rue très en colère plus de 1
million 300000 personnes descendent
manifestées dans les rues deux ans plus
tard sous le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron en novembre 2018 c'est le début
du mouvement des gilets jaunes avec
presque 300 000 manifestants lors du
premier acte et un an plus tard en 2019
ce sont les plus grosses grèves depuis
95 notamment à la SNCF et la RATP qui
paralyse la France pendant plus de 25
jours toujours contre la réforme des
retraites engagée par Emmanuel Macron et
en tout il a eu près de six grandes
périodes de grève et de manifestations
depuis 95 contre les réformes des
retraites